now rational functions what do we mean
by rational functions rational is the
adjective for the word ratio right so
what we're comparing is where you've got
in particular a polynomial on the top
and a polynomial on the bottom and you
divide okay so there's a ratio between
the two functions so the whole thing is
a rational function now where we'll
begin with is our most basic of the
rational functions
the familiar hyperbola if you can't
remember that's what these things are
called as opposed to parabolas this is
something you first encountered probably
in year 10 maybe even you know if you
were super advanced and the hyperbola I
hope is a familiar thing to graph and so
let's have a go at putting the
information onto our Cartesian plane
here and there's some important features
which you might recall from last time
it's similar with Exponential's and logs
we're looking for shape intercept and
asymptotes this time plural because the
hyperbolas tend to have more than one
and also if necessary we want to point
for scale but there's no popular singers
that I know called see up so anyway I'll
put those in brackets okay now where are
the what is the overall shape of this
thing where you've got these curvy two
separate branches that look roughly like
this one in the first quadrant in the
top right and then one in the third
quadrant in the bottom left and then
when you think about this particular
graph it actually has no intercepts
that's kind of weird and unusual most of
the other ones when you introduce a
transformation of some kind like a
translation somewhere you're going to
collide with one of the corner axes so
usually we'll get some intercepts but
not this guy and then also we have
asymptotes so there's going to be a
vertical asymptote right here along the
y axis and it's equation is x equals
zero and then also we'll have a
horizontal asymptote over here on the x
axis and accordingly it's equation is y
equals zero now in this case because I
have no intercepts not even one I
definitely definitely need a point for
scale somewhere because this graph here
I mean I'm suggesting that it's y equals
one over X but it could just as easily
be
why equals 2 over X or 1 over 2x or any
other sort of similar looking hyperbola
so I need to provide a point some set of
coordinates choose an easy value of x
that will work conveniently for you like
say x equals 1 when you put in x equals
1 you get wake was 1 over 1 so 1 is
gonna be the y coordinate as well so
I've got a point for scale this can't be
any other hyperbola it has to be 1 over
X now what I want to do is um dive
before we get into the worked examples
do I have a little more deeply into
understanding the features of this we've
talked about asymptotes before with
Exponential's and logs but with
hyperbolas with rational functions you
have to be a little more cautious so
it's worth actually thinking in more
detail about them now to understand them
better I'm gonna use an old tool that
we've used many times in the past which
is a table of values and I'd love you
for you to copy down something like this
next to your beneath your graph of 1
over X and I'm having a look at some
particular values of X and the values of
Y you get when you substitute them in so
we're actually going to know it sounds
weird but I'm actually gonna start all
the way over here because I've already
got that value when I substituted in x
equals 1 I'm gonna get Y also equals 1
and as I go to the right as my X values
increase what's happening like what does
the graph tell you and what do your
numbers tell you well as you substitute
the X values in you get 1 over 10 which
I guess you could write as naught point
1 then you get 1 over 100 which I guess
we could write as 0.01 and then at the
end of my table anyway I get 1 over
thousands so that's how many zeros is
that 0.001 okay so what you see here in
the numbers is what you would predict
based on looking at the graph up here
right as you go to the right as X values
increase you get closer and closer to
the x-axis to the horizontal asymptote
okay and that's that's why the
horizontal asymptote is there it's a
line that we're approaching and
approaching and approaching forever ok
now we can see the same thing on the
left hand side if I now look at this
spot over here I'm just looking at the
same values but negative
so I'm going to see the same kind of
pattern when I do one over substitute
the x value in you're getting at 1 over
negative 1 which is negative 1 1 over
negative 10 I'm going to skip straight
to the decimal here it's going to be
negative 0.1 then negative 0.01 and
negative 0.001 now this is the important
thing to grab out of this right on the
right hand side we noticed we were
approaching the x axis y equals 0
because look these numbers over here
they're teeny tiny right and they've
they get tinier as you go along now over
here on the left hand side we're also
getting teeny tiny these are also very
small values we're still approaching the
x axis we're still approaching y equals
0 but importantly and you can see the
graph tells you why we're not
approaching from the same direction
we're actually approaching it from the
bottom you've got negative values all
the way through this table here we're
approaching it from the bottom rather
than from the top ok now of course we
know and you can see I've delicately
avoided there there's a value right
there in the middle which I have
deliberately not evaluated which is 0
because we can't divide by 0 right
you're kind of things blow up so we've
just left that value off there but what
I want to get across to you here is this
horizontal asymptote at y equals 0 where
does it come from it comes from putting
in these very large values of X or very
large negative values of X okay so filed
out of your mind for a second now we're
going to do is focus in on this part in
the middle where we don't know what's
going on okay if I actually just look
between negative 1 and 1 if we now draw
another table of values that just
focuses on this part of the graph and
chooses some X values that are
appropriate what's going on we know
you're not allowed to put in 0 because
I'm you know that divided by 0 things
blow up but what happens when you put in
values that are sort of nearby in the
neighborhood as it were what I'm going
to do is I'm going to start at the same
place that I started before which was at
x equals 1 I already know what that
value is
it's 1 now what happens when you put in
values they get closer and closer to x
equals 0 we can't get there exactly but
I can get pretty close right
well when you put in an x value like 1
over 10 you're now getting y equals 1
over 1 over 10 so the reciprocal of 1
over 10 which is of course 10 when you
move along when you get even closer you
get the reciprocal of 1 over 100 so it's
a hundred and then like this is as far
as my table is going to go when I get to
x equals one over a thousand so this is
really really close to the y-axis it's
really close to x equals zero you of
course get a value of y equals a
thousand and again looking back up at
the graph this is exactly what we expect
what I'm looking at on my table of
values is what's happening as I go to
the left and as I go left I go up I get
higher and higher and higher
okay now maybe by now you're kind of
predicting where I'm going here right if
I do the other side and what I'm getting
is I'm the reciprocal of negative 1
which is also negative 1 the reciprocal
of negative 1 over 10 which is negative
10 negative 100 and then negative a
thousand so unlike in the table the
values above where you know as you went
to these big values of X you ended up
getting to the same spot it's just from
above or from below okay here we're
going to two completely different places
when X gets small on the positive side
you get really really big values for y
when X gets small on the negative side
you get really really negative values
for Y and again one more time can you
back to the graph that's exactly what
you should expect as you can see us
going down dropping close to x equals
zero the vertical asymptote now the
reason why I sort of dwelled on this
table values is because it shows you
that horizontal and vertical asymptotes
despite both being called asymptotes and
kind of like geometrically they look
very similar they actually a function
and behave very differently
one of them comes from when you look at
really really big values off to the
sides of your graph we would call them
extreme values things like you know x
equals a thousand x equals negative a
thousand but what about this vertical
asymptote and the behavior here well it
comes from what happens when you get
closer and closer to a spot you're not
allowed to go to right let me say that
one more time
vertical asymptotes they come
what the graph does what the function
does as you get closer to some
disallowed values some value where the
function breaks down okay now we have
language for all of this we have formal
notation that kinds of unpacks this and
it comes back to you so I'm get my
screen the right size comes back to
stuff we introduced right at the
beginning of differentiation and let's
do the horizontal asymptote for starters
we would say the limit as X approaches
infinity as X gets huge and the limit of
of this particular function well what
did we say it approached as X got really
really big we would say it's it's
getting closer and closer to zero right
we also noticed that if you put in
really really enormous negative values
on this function whoops I want that to
be bigger in the same function and you
also approach zero but then we also
pointed out that you don't approach zero
in the same way when you're approaching
from this side you're approaching from
the top and you get cushion course you
sort of drop down okay but when you're
approaching on this side you've sort of
increasing your going up so the way that
we denote that and this is a slightly
weird notation which some of you are
seeing cuz mrs. Lee's explained this in
the past and people asked about it the
way we would explain this is or write it
I should say is we approach 0 from the
top which means you know we write a plus
here to say you're coming from the top
going down and then for this one down
the bottom we say we approach it from
the underneath we approach it from the
negative direction this is weird
notation right it's not it's not like
we're saying zero is positive or
negative we're saying we're approaching
the same value from above or from below
okay now when it came to vertical
asymptotes we were doing another limit
but it wasn't as X got really big it was
as X approached this disallowed value
this value that we have a discontinuity
is the technical name now we approach it
and that discontinuity is a zero but
remember we approached it from two
different sides and you've got two
completely different behaviors right so
I'm going to use this notation that I've
just introduced zero from the positive
side or 0 from the negative side I'm
going to use these this new notation to
distinguish between the two approaches
okay so when I approach zero from the
positive side
and I look at this function what do I
get well this thing it approaches
infinity really large values denominated
gets small the whole thing gets large
goes toward infinity and by contrast
when X approaches that same sure but
from the other side when it's
approaching from the negative side which
in this case is from the left on this
function you don't approach infinity you
approach negative infinity okay now I
promise I'm almost at the end of the
sort of theory here right this is it has
really important implications for how
you graph things because what we're
saying is vertical asymptotes they come
from these domain discontinuities places
where the graph is not allowed to go you
put in x equals zero to this graph or
other values of x as you'll see in a
second for different graphs things just
blow up right so instead of going
exactly there we just try and see what
happens nearby you get asymptotic
behavior horizontal asymptotes on the
other hand they come from a completely
different idea they come from extreme
values as you get really really large
things on the left hand side or on the
right hand side of the graph and like I
said this has implications for how you
draw things for example because vertical
asymptotes come from these
discontinuities not allowed to go there
right you can never pass you can never
cross a vertical asymptote it's not
allowed as soon as you draw a vertical
asymptote on your graph you know that
your actual function will never cross it
okay
horizontal asymptotes though they're
completely different kettle of fish
you can cross horizontal asymptotes
sometimes multiple times sometimes an
infinite number of times if you have the
right function so even though we call
them both asymptotes they do actually
behave quite differently and I'm going
to give you some worked examples now
that highlight that